arielle dombasle est né ariel sonnerie
de fromental aux états unis dans le
connecticut a 18 ans quand elle vient à
paris c'est pour étudier la musique et
surtout le champ mais le cinéma la
détournera de cette passion première
eric rohmer avec perceval le gallois
initie un parcours atypique qui la
conduira l'astérix à robe grillet
insaisissable arielle dombasle épouse de
bernard henri lévy elle semble parfois
blessés par le portrait qu'on fait
d'elle troubles ont trop sophistiqué
trop tout elle ne s'y reconnaît pas la
chanson lui paraît le seul moyen d'en
offrir un fidèle c'est ce qu'elle monte
dans son dernier album c'est si bon a
sorti chez sony bmg
on retrouve les grands standards
américains des années 50 dans son
journal intime est elle s'interroge sur
son destin avec philosophie et se
demande s'il est encore possible pour
une star d'échapper au piège du
narcissisme
[Musique]
longtemps ma maxime c'était ne te
connais pas toi même et je pense que les
artistes n'ont pas à se connaître ils
sont illimitées en tout cas j'ai
l'illusion de lettres et des trains fini
aussi en perfectionnement en perpétuel
devenir est pas une image figée
un papillon épinglé pour tico tico tico
tico tico tico kikuku une maclan un vol
vss coucou je crois qu'on est le même
qu'à 90 on change pas beaucoup
le caractère et le maire l'hérédité la
même
et selon qu'on est colérique nerveux
mélancolie que gay dès la naissance ce
sont déjà des cartes qu'on a et ensuite
évidemment la vie se charge de remettre
une série d'obstacles terribles et aussi
de plaisir infini et voilà à on est dans
les toboggans de la vie j'étais une
sorte d'enfant hyperactive camp
je regarde mon parcours il paraît un peu
fou aux yeux des autres pour moi c'est
comme une sorte de 2,2 mosaïque qui à
son sens secret j'ai énormément liberté
c'est une liberté acquise et à laquelle
je tiens plus que tout je suis vraiment
un oiseau libre
[Musique]
je vous savez cette enfance et
adolescence catholique mexicaine élevé
beaucoup par la cuisinière et man and i
est donc j'ai suivi beaucoup de
pèlerinage populaire j'ai été trés dans
la mystique catholique mexicaine
j'ai adoré cette ça m'a vraiment formés
alors vous savez j'ai aussi comme tout
le monde
le rationalisme cartésien qu'on nous
apprend à l'école et dans lequel on
baigne
d'une certaine manière une partie de
votre pensée riz de l'autre mais je ne
peux pas m'abstraire du fait que pour
moi ce moment de moustiques catholiques
sont quand même au coeur de moi même je
les aime je le shérif et sont très
importants pour moi je dis toujours je
pense que c'est très peu moi je suis né
gay
les mexicains ou un rapport à la mort
tellement c'est le seul pays où le jour
des morts ou un manche de cadavres en
sus on danse avec les cales à castres ou
fait semblant que la mort est une chose
absolument apprivoiser on s'en moque on
rigole on fait des festins le jour des
morts on ouvre les tombes et on apporte
mort des enfants et c'est évidemment
très très payant et le catholicisme
venus par dessus donc tout ça fait un
drôle de mélange ça m'a beaucoup marqué
et puis après quand il ya la réalité de
la mort qui arrive quand on est un
enfant évidemment moment ça
ça bouleverse et tous à tout jamais
c'est même difficile d'en parler comme
ça parce que c' est quelque chose qui
vous met hors du rang des autres
[Musique]
je vous manquer de confiance en moi mais
c'est même au delà je pensais être un
personnage mais totalement insignifiant
une espèce de petite paille dans un
fleuve et quand on commence à travailler
et que les gens commencent à vous faire
mais à être à faire naître la valeur que
vous avez en vous alors ça et rohmer
c'est sa grand mère c'est comme un
grand-oncle adorable qui est le premier
cinéaste qui m'a fait exister le premier
qui m'a rendu bell qui a pensé que
j'étais quelqu'un d'intéressant qui m'a
regardé ça c'est inoubliable cet
inestimable
[Musique]
pour m
le narcissisme cet été ce n'est pas
intéressant comme sentiment nous est
avalée par soi même il ya une espèce
d'autosatisfaction très désagréable et
moi je ne l'est pas quand je me regarde
je me regarde plutôt comme un objet
différent que moi la beauté vient quand
on a des regard aimant sur soi alors là
on s'épanouit tout à coup on se sent
belle et c'est ça qui est merveilleux
quand les gens commencent à vous aimer
on devient belle avant devient pas belle
c'est tout une question de regard sur
soi des autres
tout à coup on est objet de désir on est
obligé d'attention les objets
d'admiration on est au g2a alors on se
dit c'est vrai tout ça c'est pour moi et
alors là on devient belle
celle
s'il ya quelque chose de mon tanguay de
tris dans mon regard que l'on me dit
souvent c'est parce que ce que j'ai vécu
probablement c'est très banal comme tous
il y a des moments d'intense gaieté il y
en a vraiment beaucoup et puis aussi des
très grande dévastation décrit très
grands tourments comme tout le monde
donc ça se boit d'une manière ou d'une
autre ça se voit
[Musique]